thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description will get a one month
free trial of skillshare's premium
membership
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
for those of you afraid of spiders the
micro cosmos probably seems like a safe
haven when you're scanning through a
microscopic ocean full of single-celled
organisms the likelihood of a spider
crawling across your screen feels
comfortably low
the few times we've seen a spider under
the microscope it's because we put it
there
but safe as the micro cosmos might seem
from a surprise spider attack it would
be misleading to pretend that it is
completely free of spider-like sightings
because even at this small scale you
could still find yourself subject to an
ambush of the arachnid sort
[Music]
these are water mites relatives of
spiders in that they are also members of
the arachnid class and the resemblance
is uncanny especially with all of those
eight legs waving around
but that detail aside there is something
about this water mite that looks more
like a cartoon spider something you
might have doodled in a notebook for one
there's the eyes those simple dots
water mite species usually have two
pairs which mainly act to detect light
it's much less intimidating to stare
into the eyes of the water mite than
into the eight eyes of a spider
another reason for the cartoon
spideriness of some water mites is down
to a defining aspect of their shape
spiders have segmented bodies with an
abdomen that is distinct from the
cephalothorax that holds its head but
water mites are not segmented instead
those different parts are fused together
in the case of this particular species
the final result is round and kind of
adorable
so now we're going to disrupt that
cuteness by bringing up a creature that
we've talked about before one that's
more closely related to water mites and
one that does not evoke any sense of
cuteness
we're talking about dust mites which are
part of the same super order of mites
called akiriformis
if you haven't watched our episode about
dust mites before you should check it
out after you watch this video
especially if you're looking for
motivation to clean your room because
without spoiling too much the main thing
to know about dust mites is that their
poop
is it's not great
i'm bringing that up now because while
water might poop might not evoke the
same concern the dust mite poop does it
is still fascinating their excretory
system is made up of a large tube
connected to a pore
the tube takes in waste from the mites
version of blood called hemolymph and in
the tube the waste is stored as yellow
or white crystals to clear out its
storage of crystals the mite simply
moves its muscles to push everything
through its excretory pore
from the studies we've found on other
mites with similar systems our best
guess is that these poops are guanine
crystals produced by the mites body as
it breaks down nutrients now crystal
poop
is weird but the weirder thing is that
crystalline poop is not the weirdest
thing that water mites excrete but
before we get there let's talk about
just how red some of our water mites are
they're so red that they might seem like
walking drops of blood
they are not actually chock full of
blood though the red color is likely
some kind of carotenoid that turns the
water mite crimson and for a time
scientists believed that the red color
was a way for these species of water
mites to flash a warning signal to fish
sort of a do not eat me expressed solely
through a threatening hue
but like why why did scientists think
fish would heed this warning anyway why
would a fish bother to listen to a water
mite when it could be eating the water
might instead
[Music]
well many water mite species have an
approach to warding off predators that
is
sticky
water mites have little globe-shaped
organs dotting their bodies called
glandularia
each with a little opening and a little
bristly hair called a ceta when
something say a fish brushes up against
that hair it triggers the glandularia
into releasing a milky fluid into the
water where it mixes into a tackier more
viscous substance and for predators the
idea of having to wade through some
gloppy mess to get to your food is
probably unappealing so when the
scientists saw in the context of their
own experiments that fish seemed to
quickly stop trying to eat water mites
they decided the red coloring was
watermite's way of telling fish we're
the sticky prey but while it's possible
the fish do learn to not pick out these
water mites for food the idea that their
red color exists specifically as a
warning to predators does not hold up to
the basics of how these particular
species live
mite species tend to be found in
transient pools of water places that
fish don't often find themselves so the
likelihood that they would have evolved
this trait for the purpose of warning
fish is low it's more likely that the
pigments are a way of protecting them
from ultraviolet light it just maybe
happened to also protect them from fish
as well and the sticky fluid that makes
them unappealing to fish also has
another use
reproduction
in one genus called a renerist the males
use it to hold the female still during
copulation
this is part of a wider spectrum of
weird reproductive behaviors on one end
there are the species like the ones we
just mentioned which engage very
directly and physically with each other
on the other end of the spectrum there
are water mite species where the sexes
don't feel the need to interact at all
to make reproduction happen they don't
communicate they don't touch the males
simply deposit spermatophores somewhere
for the female counterparts to find them
and pick them up and then somewhere
between the directly copulating water
mites in the cold shoulder water mites
there are the dancers
they're sort of like the second group in
that males drop off their spermatophores
but they actually stick around mostly so
they can draw females in and help them
find the spermatophores and this is
where the dancing comes in sometimes
this involves vibrating their legs to
mimic their favorite prey drawing the
attention and aggression of wandering
females
other times though this means waltzing
together as a pair moving in circles
with careful pauses to pick up the
spermatophores we obviously don't have a
video of that or else we would be
showing it to you but at some point some
scientists watched that happen
someone watched the dance of the mating
water mites and they carefully
documented it just like someone saw the
mitaverse fish and the crystal poops and
the many other strange things that make
up the lives of water mites
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
and we'd like to say thank you again to
skillshare for supporting this video
maybe you are a little overwhelmed with
all the spidery imagery in this video
well how about spending some time with a
different kind of spider on skillshare
you can learn everything from how to
draw spiderman to how to transplant a
spider plant so whether you're looking
to flex your creative muscles or take
care of that unhappy houseplant in the
corner of your room skillshare is there
for you skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for anyone who loves to learn
and wants to explore their creativity
and learn new skills with so much to
explore and real world projects to
create skillshare empowers you to
accomplish real growth it's curated
specifically for learning meaning there
are no ads to distract you and they're
always launching new premium classes so
you can stay focused on leveling up your
skills and if you're one of the first
thousand people to click the link in the
description you can get a one month free
trial of skillshare's premium membership
the names on the screen right now these
are our patreon patrons they are the
people who make it possible for us to do
this thing and i am so grateful to you
because before this channel started i
knew that i would be interested in this
stuff but i did not know anything about
it yet and now i know so much and i hope
that by coming on this journey with us
you do too and actually the video in the
background here of these little mites
you're seeing that's actually from my
micro cosmos microscope i found some
mites in my local pond like the same
week that we were making this video so i
sent them to our editor and they're
getting edited in
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there is
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
you